necesitamos balancear la reacción redox
para la batería de níquel cambio y esto
es lo que pasa cambio metálico más
hidróxido de óxido de níquel nos da
hidróxido de cadmio e hidróxido de
níquel y en la batería esto sucede en
una solución básica ya hemos visto cómo
balancear una reacción redox en una
solución básica demostré antes un vídeo
con todos los pasos así que este vídeo
es un repaso de lo que se debe hacer
recuerda qué pretendes que es una
solución ácida y luego puedes cambiarla
a una solución básica el primer paso es
asignar estados de oxidación así que
empezamos con cadmio metálico y para el
metal cadmio esto es sólo un elemento
por lo que el estado de oxidación es
cero luego para el hidróxido de óxido de
níquel sabes que el hidróxido es
h - y el oxígeno es o dos menos y por lo
tanto el níquel deberá hacer ni que el 3
más para balancear eso por lo que esto
debería de ser el guión
mikel 3 más el cual tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 3 para el hidróxido de
cadmio sabemos que el hidróxido es una
carga de menos 1 y tenemos dos de ellos
así que esto deberá de ser el guión
cambió 2 más el cual tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 2
para el hidróxido de níquel o ocurre lo
mismo
teníamos 2 hidróxidos así que este
debería de ser
mikel 2 más el ion níquel 2 más lo que
significa que el estado de oxidación es
más dos primero escribimos nuestras
medias reacciones de oxidación hagamos
eso veamos qué es lo que se oxida en
nuestra batería el cambio metálico va de
un estado de oxidación de cero a un
estado de oxidación de más dos en el
cambio dos más eso es un aumento en el
estado de oxidación por lo que eso es
oxidación escribimos nuestra media
reacción tenemos cadmio metálico yendo a
hidróxido de cadmio
luego vemos los átomos que tenemos que
balancear empezamos con el cambio
tenemos un cadmio en la izquierda y un
cambio en la derecha por lo que el
cambio está balanceado
luego balanceamos oxígenos cuántos
oxígenos hay en el lado derecho bueno
hay dos porque este 2 afecta a todo lo
que está dentro del paréntesis así que
hay 2 oxígenos en la derecha y 0
oxígenos en la izquierda balanceados al
oxígeno agregando agua así que cuántas
moléculas de agua necesitamos añadir al
lado izquierdo para balancear oxígeno
necesitaríamos 2 así que si añadimos dos
moléculas de agua ahora tenemos dos
oxígenos en la izquierda y los oxígenos
a la derecha luego balanceamos el
hidrógeno y vamos a pretender que esto
está en solución ácida
así que balanceamos el hidrógeno
añadiendo protones
añadiendo h más cuántos hidrógenos del
lado izquierdo dos por dos es cuatro
tenemos cuatro hidrógenos en la
izquierda cuántos en la derecha hay dos
hidrógenos en la derecha así que tenemos
que añadir dos protones al lado derecho
para balancear el hidrógeno así que
añadiremos 2 h más al lado derecho
pretendimos que esto estaba en solución
ácida pero recuerda que de hecho está en
solución básica
podemos agregar hidróxido a ambos lados
para remover el h más teníamos 2 h más
tenemos que añadir 2
h - y si añadimos 2 hidróxidos al lado
derecho tenemos que añadir 2 hidróxidos
al lado izquierdo escribamos lo que
tendremos para nuestra media reacción de
oxidación tenemos 2 h2o así que tenemos
2 h2o más cadmio más cadmio más 2
hidróxidos más 2 hidróxidos dándonos
hidróxido de cadmio
de o h2 y qué es esto qué es
2 h + + 2 o h - h más o menos te darán
agua así que obtendrás dos moléculas de
agua en el lado derecho tenemos 2 h2o
luego tenemos que balancear nuestra
carga fijémonos en la carga para media
reacción de oxidación en el lado
izquierdo cuál es la carga total tenemos
2 hidróxidos eso es una carga de 2 - en
el lado derecho tenemos una carga de 0
una carga total de 0 balanceamos la
carga añadiendo electrones así que
cuantos electrones añadiremos y en qué
lado de nuestra media reacción los
sumamos si añadimos 2 electrones en el
lado derecho
eso balance haría nuestra carga
añadiremos los electrones al lado
derecho nota que tenemos dos moléculas
de agua en la izquierda y dos moléculas
de agua en la derecha por lo que podemos
cancelar las y escribamos nuestra media
reacción final cadmio + 2 hidróxido nos
da
hidróxido de cadmio
+ 2 electrones
esto es una oxidación por lo que
deberíamos de estar perdiendo electrones
aquí en nuestra media reacción estamos
listos para escribir nuestra media
reacción de reducción a continuación
haremos reducción
nuestra media reacción de oxidación
ocurre en el ánodo de nuestra batería la
reacción de reducción ocurre en el
cátodo de nuestra batería volvamos aquí
arriba para ver lo que escribiremos como
nuestra media reacción de reducción esto
va de un estado de oxidación de más 3 a
un estado de oxidación de más 2 hay una
disminución o reducción en el estado de
oxidación esta sería nuestra media
reacción el hidróxido de óxido de níquel
yendo a hidróxido de níquel escribamos
eso tenemos hidróxido de óxido
mikel yendo a hidróxido de níquel
para nuestra mitad de reacción de
reducción
empezamos balanceando nuestros átomos un
níquel en la izquierda unikel en la
derecha
luego el oxígeno 2 oxígenos en la
izquierda y 2 oxígenos en la derecha así
que podemos movernos al hidrógeno
cuántos hidrógenos hay de lado izquierdo
sólo hay 11 hidrógeno en la izquierda
pero hay dos hidrógenos en la derecha
vamos a pretender que esto está en
solución ácida balanceamos hidrógenos
sumando protones cuatros protones
añadimos y en qué lado bueno tenemos dos
hidrógenos en la derecha y sólo uno en
la izquierda tenemos que añadir un
protón al lado izquierdo añadiremos un
protón h más ahora el hidrógeno está
balanceado luego nos vamos a deshacer
del protón que acabamos de añadir porque
está realmente no es una solución ácida
ya que tenemos un protón necesitamos
añadir un ínter óxido para deshacernos
de ese protón
si añadimos un hidróxido al lado
izquierdo tenemos que agregar un
hidróxido al lado derecho en nuestra
media reacción escribamos lo que tenemos
ahora h más y h nos da h2o tenemos h2o
más hidróxido de óxido de níquel
h2o más hidróxido de óxido de níquel lo
que nos da en el lado derecho tendríamos
hidróxido de níquel hidróxido de níquel
más o h - más hidróxido
después tenemos que balancear la carga
veamos la carga total en la izquierda
sería 0 en el lado derecho tenemos una
unión hidróxido eso es 1 - para la carga
en la derecha así que tenemos que añadir
un electrón al lado izquierdo de nuestra
media reacción si añadimos un electrón
al lado izquierdo
ahora las cargas están balanceadas es
menos 1 de la izquierda y menos 1 en la
derecha
así que añadimos un electrón
la ganancia de electrones y reducción lo
que tiene sentido también esta es
nuestra media reacción esta es nuestra
media reacción de reducción y estamos
listos para pensar en sumar nuestras dos
reacciones volvamos aquí arriba y
recuerda esta fue nuestra media reacción
de oxidación así que perdimos dos
electrones
perdimos dos electrones en nuestra media
reacción de oxidación
cuando pones juntas sus medias
reacciones el número de electrones tiene
que ser igual porque los electrones que
se pierden en la media reacción de
oxidación son los mismos electrones que
se ganaron en la media reacción de
reducción tenemos que tener dos
electrones para nuestra media reacción
de reducción podemos obtener dos
electrones
y multiplicar todo
lo de nuestra media reacción de
reducción por 2 multiplicaremos todo
esto por 2 2 por 1 nos da 2 electrones y
luego 2 por h2o nos da dos moléculas de
agua obtenemos 2 hidróxidos de óxido de
níquel 2 m
h obtendremos 2 hidróxidos de níquel 2
hidróxidos de níquel y finalmente 2 e
hidróxidos ahora tenemos el número de
electrones ahora tenemos el mismo número
de electrones ahora podemos sumar todo
junto para obtener nuestra reacción
total para nuestra batería níquel-cadmio
sumaremos sumaremos las dos medias
reacciones que enmarca esta media
reacción y esta media reacción vamos a
sumar las juntas
o podemos cancelar algunas cosas ahorita
para hacer nuestras vidas un poco más
fáciles voy a cancelar estos electrones
en el lado de los productos y estos en
el lado de las reacciones y podemos
cancelar el hidróxido porque si te fijas
déjame cambiar los colores aquí tenemos
2 hidróxidos en el lado de reactivos y 2
hidróxidos en el lado de los productos
ahora podemos escribir nuestra reacción
total así que para esta mitad de
reacción
tenemos cadmio así que escribamos eso
aquí tenemos cadmio metálico + 2 h2o + 2
h2o + 2 hidróxidos de óxido de níquel +
2 hidróxidos de óxido de níquel
que tendríamos como productos tendríamos
bueno volvamos aquí arriba a nuestra
media reacción de oxidación tendríamos
hidróxido de cadmio escribiremos eso
hidróxido de cadmio más aquí abajo
tendremos dos hidróxidos de níquel +2
hidróxido de níquel así que finalmente
terminamos esta es la reacción total
para lo que ocurre en una batería níquel
cadmio y nuestros dos productos
hidróxido de cadmio e hidróxido de
níquel ambos son sólidos que se
precipitan en los electrodos de la
batería y eso facilita revertir la
reacción porque si revierte la reacción
tienes que empezar tienes que empezar
con hidróxido de cadmio e hidróxido de
níquel y esos ya están ahí así que es
fácil revertir esta reacción lo que
facilita recargar esta batería por lo
que la batería de níquel
es como la batería de plomo de
almacenamiento es recargable y por lo
tanto puede ser muy útil